Listen to me, please.
I'm a seasoned mother of four children.
One of them is disabled. Every single fucking morning,
I gotta get their little dusty,
crusty asses up and out the door in time.
And that little clock,
this clock from the TikTok shop is a fucking lifesaver.
I went to bed like, I love that clock.
I love. I can't get over how much I love this fucking clock.
It has a little remote, okay?
So first of all, it tells you the day of the week,
the time, the date and the temperature inside your house.
Not only that, but it has a remote,
and you can change the color of the light.
Green. This button has.
It has a stopwatch feature.
And then it also has a timer feature.
So you can push the button
and it's gonna start acting like a stopwatch.
You push this button, and now we have a timer.
I could tell everybody, you got three minutes until it's time to go.
And everybody can see the clock to see that we got.
We gotta go, guys.
We can hear the timer.
Alarm 1, alarm 2.
This thing linked right here in the TikTok shop is a laser,
and it comes in a bunch of colors.
I got the multi color, but you could get it pink,
green, blue, whatever.
So I. I'm not kidding.
This is one of my fucking favorite things from the TikTok shop.
So fucking perfect for getting Kids ready and out the door on time.